so hallo Samy das freut mich Dich
persönlich jetzt endlich mal in 3D hier
zu begrüßen freut mich ebenfalls in
Stuttgart du bist gespannt ja ein
bisschen aufgeregt aber das legt sich
glaube ich das gehört dazu bin ich auch
so wir haben da drüben die Ecke
eingerichtet hat ihr schon gesehen bitte
und zwar der linke Sessel mit
G so
sehr schön jetzt machen wir g richtig
n vielen
Dank ja hallo Samy hallo Herr Tutorial
wie ist die Lage ich habe es schon
bisschen mitbekommen du wirst auf der
Straße erkannt an allen Ecken und Enden
was ich bei dir faszinierend finde du
bist ja kein aufgebauter Star sondern
das hat sich in anfhrung Zeichen so
ergeben ganz genau habe ich das richtig
zusammengefasst sehr genau
zusammengefasst und ja einfach gestartet
auf Youtube ein Video hochgeladen und es
hat sein Lauf genommen warum ist das bei
dir der Fall gewesen bei anderen nicht
ich würde einfach mal denken dass ich
Videos für die Allgemeinheit mach sie so
gestalte dass sie Unterhaltungswert
haben Tipps und Tricks beinhalten und
einfach ich selbst bin und da das ist
glaube ich auch
mein
geheim Tipp an alle die erfolgreich
werden wollen das heißt nicht verstellen
nein ganz natürlich bleiben ja machen
das andere meinst du dass du wenn du
wirst ja wahrscheinlich auch ein
bisschen geguckt haben vorher was machen
die anderen wie muss ich das machen ja
einige Spiel ne wie soll ich sagen wie
könte ich das
sagen ich würde mal sagen das liegt je
nachdem was man auf youtube ist Guru
Comedien Director je nachdem muss man
sich auch einer gewissen Rolle anpassen
und als Guru kann ich einfach natürlich
sein und einfach meine Tipps an den Mann
bringen ist das dir ein Anliegen gewesen
deine Tipps oder hast du überlegt hey
das ist so toll Youtube da will ich was
machen was war so der Anfang der Idee
also ich wollte schon immer mal Videos
machen und dann habe ich auch auf
YouTube rumgeschaut und andere Gurus
entdeckt überwiegend weibliche und ich
habe mir dann gedacht ein männlicher
Guru das wä was
und so denke ich mal war es was ganz
Neues für die für die User auf YouTube
und es ging D ratzfatz wobei du ja Tipps
auch vor allem für für die weibliche
zuseherschaft machst zum Teil also ich
versuche meine Tipps allgemein zu halten
männliche und weibliche User
anzusprechen und ich versuche einfach so
ein Mittelding zu finden damit ich
einfach beide Seiten ansprech Frage du
machst sowas wie Augenbrauen zupfen wie
Nagelpflege
Hautpflege und so weiter und so fortt
ähm war hat das dich schon immer vorher
interessiert oder hast du dich da
eingearbeitet ich würde mal sagen ich
habe mich da wirklich eingearbeitet es
war
anfangs ich habe mich halt einfach mit
Männerkosmetik beschäftigt Männerpflege
ist besonders jetzt im Vormarsch und
durch diese ganze Youtube Sache habe ich
mich da immer mehr dafür interessiert
und auch in meine Videos mit einfließen
lassen wie gehst Du daran wenn du jetzt
ein Video machst also ich setze mich hin
überleg mir was für ein Thema könnte gut
ankommen was für ein Thema ist
vielleicht ge frrag von meinen Zuschauer
und ich bin auch in ständigen Kontakt
wiea Twitter mit meinen Zuschauern und
auf diese Weise können sie mir auch
Vorschläge machen und die beziehe ich
dann auch mit ein und so komme ich auf
meine Videoideen Skripte Sie auch
manchmal schreib mir auch was ich
vielleicht sagen will um ein roten Faden
zu verfolgen und ja wie gehst du dann
ran ich sag mal wenn du so ein Thema
hast Nagelpflege da musst du ja dieses
Gebiet irgendwie abarbeiten da musst ja
so du musst ja wirklich ein Experte
dafür werden für dieses eine Video ja da
habe ich ja zwei Schwestern die kann ich
sehr gut ja mit einbeziehen Fragen und
Tipps und Tricks von ihnen erfahren und
auch an meine Zuschauer dann weitergeben
ich gehe auch manchmal in die Bibliothek
Suche nach verschiedenen Büchern und
informiere mich dann kann man das als
Journalismus beschreiben
schönheitsjournalismus könnte man
vielleicht so sagen weil man
recherchiert ja auch und um möglichst
gute Tipps zu machen zu haben hast du
dir das dann selber beigebracht ich sag
mal die journalistischen Fähigkeiten
weil man wenn man recherchiert eine man
kann in Wikipedia gucken ja klar ne aber
das machen viele und da passieren viele
feh ja aber wie vermeidest du
das ja ich würde mal sagen learning by
doing selber ausprobieren selber testen
sehen ob diese Tipps und Tricks wirklich
wirken und ob sich es lohnt die auch an
meine Zuschauer weiterzugeben und so
vermeide ich Fehler und das heißt das
machst du wirklich du wendest das an
ganz genau alles was man bei dir sieht
hast du mal an dir selber ausprobiert ja
auf alle Fälle was war das Unangenehmste
das Unangenehmste würde ich mal sagen
war meine
kaffeemaske ja da hat alles gekrümelt
Flecken auf meinem T-Shirt aber das habe
ich dann auch in Video gesagt aufpassen
wie damit rumhtiert nicht dass ihr
Flecken anschließend Flecken auf euren
T-Shirt und hast du die bereut die
kaffeemaske oder also die Wirkung war
wirklich sehr gut und das Feedback von
den Zuschauern war auch sehr positiv und
da habe ich mich auch bestätigt gefühlt
dass es auch wirkt und ist das
vielleicht Vorteil von Youtube dass man
auch sehr schnell lernt weil man ständig
Rückkopplung bekommt von den zuschau
ganz genau also das Feedback der
Zuschauer auf dem basiert ja auch alles
auf dem basiert was man macht und wie
man es macht wie war das am Anfang hast
du dich verändert gegenüber dem Anfang
oder anfangs war ich viel schüchterner
noch vor der Kamera zu stehen schier
selbst mit mir zu reden und mittlerweile
ist es für mich ganz normal einfach vor
der Kamera zu stehen im leeren Raum zu
stehen und mit mir selber so zuusagen zu
reden stehst Du dann immer so ein
bisschen Sel neben dir und guckst auf
dich ich schau manchmal weg aus der
Kamera um zu überlegen was will ich
jetzt sagen und ja also es ist ein
komisches Gefühl für jeden der damit
anfängt aber irgendwann irgendwann
geht's ja und du sagst du warst
schüchtern warum hast du das dann
gemacht wollst du vielleicht die
schüchternhit überwinden nein das war
jetzt eigentlich nicht das neö das war
eigentlich nicht der Grund wieso ich mit
YouTube angefangen habe das
war man lernt einfach also man wird
einfach vor der Kamera selbstbewusster
und es ist noch kein Meister V h
gefallen würde ich mal sagen und ü macht
den Meister ja wobei dich sehen jetzt du
hast ztausende Abonnenten das geht in
die was war deine höchste Quote bisher
pro Video also
420 000 420 000 wenn man sich blamiert
blamiert man sich vor 420 000 Menschen
ist nicht so schön ja ist auch aber auch
nicht von vielen akzeptiert dass ein
Junge gerade im Internet zu Pflegetipps
gibt
und viele würden sich sowas nicht trauen
weil sie Angst hätten sich zu blamieren
aber ich stehe da vollkommen dahinter
und solange man hinter hinter einer
Sache steht kann man sich nie blamieren
gut aber wir erleben es auch es gibt
Hater ja die und es tut immer ein
bisschen weh also mir tut es immer man
fragt sich ach was habe ich denn wieso
und oder pert das inzwischen an dir ab
also ich habe es immer so gesagt dass
Hater
sozusagen das ist so ein Zitat eines
meiner Lieblingszitate Hater sind wie
Papier sie können sich an dir reiben sie
können sich an
mir zerkratzen aber am Ende bin ich der
ausgeschliffene Diamant und sie sind
abgeschliffenes Sandpapier ja hab ich
halt also ist auch was Gutes was ein
weiterbringt ja ich denke ja immer hey
ein Hater Kommentar der provoziert ja
auch wieder ganz viele sich das
anzugucken das ist ja wieder das
Positive ja also hinter jedem Erfolg
stecken Hater und ja wie gehst du mit
denen um löschst du die oder was machst
du also bei mir ist es eigentlich egal
also so ich lass sie einfach jeder
Kommentar ist ein Pluspunkt in der meist
diskutierten Liste und genau
und ja ich ignoriere es man lernt es
auch zu ignorieren und dass man das sage
ich mir auch sehr oft selber und das ist
auch mein Prinzip schon seit Anfang auf
Youtube dass man bei überpositiven
Kommentaren immer auf dem Boden bleiben
sollte und bei Hater Kommentaren Sie
sich einfach nicht an sich ranlassen
also muss da schon sich ein bisschen
Panzer aufbauen Panzer aufbauen ganz
genau du hast sagt hier das ist jeder
Kommentar ist ein Pluspunkt auf der
Liste der der Kommentare du bist ja so
ein bisschen Rekordjäger du sagst hey
abonniert mich kommentiert mich ich du
stellst Fragen an die Zuschauer damit
eben auch viele Kommentare
reinkommen wo willst du
hin wo ich hin will ich möchte einfach
dass so viele Menschen wie möglich Spaß
an meinen Videos haben dass ih dieser
Unterhaltungsfaktor geboten ist dass sie
vielleicht ich bekomme viele Kommentare
die einfach sagen du hast mein Tag
gerettet ich hatte heute so so ein
schlechten Tag als ich dein Video
gesehen habe ging es mir wieder gut und
ich möchte es einfach verbreiten diese
positive Energie die ich in meinen
Videos
ausstrahle ja gut dann anders gefragt wo
führt das
hin wo führt das hin wo führt das
hin du meinst jetzt mein Erfolg
ja das weiß ich nicht das ist ja gerade
das ich weiß nicht was jetzt noch in
Zukunft durch diese ganze Youtube
Geschichte passieren wird du hast noch
nicht überlegt also wenn jetzt das
passiert mache ich das wenn jetzt das
passiert mache ich das das hast Du ich
sag mal ignor blendest du aus oder ich
lass es einfach auf mich zukommen
genauso wie dies Interview das habe ich
jetzt auch nicht erwartet und
ja okay du bist also sehr offen was
alles betrifft das heißt könntest du dir
vorstellen das beruflich zu machen ja
ich könnte mir schon vorstellen so in
die Kosmetikbranche einzusteigen zeigen
mit vielleicht meinen eigenen Produkten
die ich dann auch sehr gut vermarkten
kann und ich denke wenn sowas kann nur
erfolgreich werden wenn man sowas
zusammen mit Zuschauern also mit dem
Feedback der Zuschauer zusammen aufbaut
das heißt quasi dir schibt sowas vor wie
ein internetprodukt du bringst was aus
dem Markt es kommt Rückkopplung
quasi wie ein Kommentar du veränderst
das Produkt wieder es geht wieder auf
dem Markt in der veränderten und so
weiter und soofort und entsteht das
optimale Produkt was den Zuschauern dann
gefallen wird garantiert aber du hast
auch ein Berufswunsch ja oder tritt
immer mehr in den Hintergrund jetzt
durch den erfol ne eigentlich nicht also
ich will immer noch MTV Moderator werden
wenn ich das so sagen
darf ja aber ich baue mir sozusagen
meine eigene zuschauerbasis auf und das
macht mir immer mehr Spaß dieses so der
Moderator meiner eigenen Show zu sein du
willst MTV Moderator werden weil meine
Info war du willst Eventmanager werden
und Medienmanagement studieren okay nee
das hat sich natürlich jetzt auch
abgewandelt ich möchte einfach ich habe
gemerkt dass es mir Spaß macht vor der
Kamera zu stehen und einfach ein
Moderator zu sein einer meiner
Lieblingssendungen wä halt der optimale
Berufswunsch mhm das heißt sowas auch im
Fernsehen zu machen wobei das was du da
machst löst ja wahrscheinlich das
Fernsehen ab weil das was sie bei dir
sehen das sitzen sie nicht vor der Kiste
und glzen MTV ja das ist aber immer ein
Vorteil sozusagen
dieser den Fernsehen sozusagen zu zeigen
dass man selber sich sowas selber
aufbauen kann dass man ich sollte nicht
zu viel rumfuchteln es ist überhaupt
kein Problem ja vielleicht störst in der
Kamera ja das ist es ja gerade ich zeig
sozusagen dem Fernsehen dass selbst ein
einzeln noch vor der Kamera mit
einfachsten Mitteln
einattkoten bekommen kann der auch nicht
du hast jetzt gerade üb rumfuchteln
erzählt du bist ja nicht perfekt weil du
authentisch bist und das wird honoriert
in der Form dass die Leute dich
abonnieren dich gut finden deine Fans
sind und dieser ich sag mal perfekte Typ
von MTV wie wir sie bisher gesehen haben
ist vielleicht gar nicht mehr
gewünscht ja vielleicht bringe ich was
anderes ja und paar Veränderungen was
ist das denn für ein Gefühl in dem
Moment wo man merkt verdammt jetzt werde
ich hier wirklich in die Öffentlichkeit
gespült ja man merkt es ja auch immer
mehr wenn ich jetzt auf der Straße
unterwegs bin dass mich Leute so wie
gerade eben also wiedererkennen und mich
ansprechen manche zittern schreien und
wollen Fotos mit mir und das ist ein
komisches Gefühl aber
ich bleib normal wie ich bin immer auf
dem Boden bleiben wobei es hat sich was
für dich geändert du hast das in deinem
letzt jahresvo gesagt du hast vieles
gelernt du hast z. gelernt dass aus
besten Freunden die größten Feinde
werden können ganz genau und es ist auch
umgekehrt aus den größten Feinden werden
plötzlich die besten Freunde das ist das
ist das ist bei jedem Erfolg so bei
jedem Menschen der Erfolg hat da kommen
immer falsche Menschen da muss man auf
jeden Fall aufpassen du hast ja
Beziehung zu die Menschen die dich
gucken ne die twittern mit dir die
schreiben dir Kommentare Mails du
antwortest nicht auf alle aber auf viele
du hast irsinnig viel Weihnachtspost und
neujahrspost bekommen du stehst denn du
hast da einen erweiterten Freundeskreis
ja kann man so sagen so eine Online
Community die dieselben Hobbys und
Interessen mit mir teilt so kann man es
beschreiben was hat sich da für dich in
so in deinem Leben hast du denn
überhaupt noch Zeit dann für deine alten
Freundin so viel Zeit wie möglich zu
nehmen also man sollte das eine nicht
vernachlässigen ja wie kriegst das hin
Zeitmanagement ja das ist wichtig also
ich muss wirklich mit einem Terminplaner
planen da habe ich Zeit da will ich mein
Video machen solangee werde ich für das
Video brauchen zum Schneiden zum
Vorbereiten und da muss immer ein
bisschen Zeit gefunden werden also über
es geht nichts über Zeitmanagement das
heißt du gehst dann zu deinem Freund son
sag so ich habe jetzt ein sein Fenster
von 15 Minuten nein also es ist eher so
dass ich mir einfach sag sobald ich
damit fertig bin habe ich Zeit für meine
Freunde und Familie die sollte auch
nicht zu kurz kommen aber trotzdem noch
mal nachgefragt
wie hat sich das dann jetzt für dich
verändert wenn da Freunde eben nicht
mehr da sind wenn vielleicht falsche
Freunde kommen wie kann man das dann
organisieren also nicht nur zeitlich
sondern auch persönlich also ich weiß
mittlerweile schon ganz genau wer meine
Freunde sind wer hinter mir steht und
voll und ganz bei der Sache ist und mir
mich auch unterstützt und es gibt halt
auch immer diejenigen die dann halt erst
jetzt kommen und da weiß man schon also
man lernt es schon zu unterscheiden ja
aber trotzdem das ist ja das
interessante bei dir dass das eben
gerade zuerst anfängt ja wenn die dann
erst jetzt kommen wie kommen die oder
was machst du dann wie reagierst du dann
du musst dich ja denen gegenüber auch
Verhalten ganz normal also Hallo und
Tschüss ja und Tschüss aber das hättest
Du vorher vielleicht nicht gesagt son
hät auch nett dass du mich interessant
findest jetzt weißt du aber nicht ist es
meine Popularität die sie interessant
finden ja also du kannst es nicht
beantworten wür du sagen ja deswegen
schwere
Frage schwere Frage
unbeantwortbar ganz genau also das werde
ich vielleicht noch lernen um genau
unterscheiden zu können wer ist richtig
wer ist
falsch okay ist aber ist natürlich auch
eine Schwierigkeit
weil ich habe es gelesen ich weiß nicht
ob es stimmt weil ich kann nicht alle
Videos von dir gucken H ben aber du hast
selber keine
Beziehung ja ganz genau
aber man lernt auch aus Erfahrungen
andere würde ich mal sagen und diese
kann ich super in mein Videos umsetzen
aber du konnst sie selber noch nicht
umsetzen nein noch nicht das wird ja
auch immer schwieriger dann Partner zu
finden wo man weil wie
willst ja das wird auch immer schwerer
irgendwann kommen die gris ja sind schon
gekommen soll ich sagen es gibt immer
welche wobei ich sie nicht als Groupies
bezeichne das hat sich ein bisschen
komisch anen ich w also ich versuche
auch so ein Verhältnis zu meinen
Zuschauern zu haben dass sie meine
Zuschauer sind sind nicht nur Abonnenten
es sind Menschen für mich das sind
Menschen dieselben Interessen mit mir
teilen und ich versuch es auch dabei zu
lassen ich will jetzt nicht großartig
Fans und Groupies und solche Worte
benutze ich eh selten aber es wird
irgendwann Fanclub entstehen gibt schon
Gion auf den verschiedensten Seiten dann
gibt's die hauptfans ja die werden auf
eine engere Beziehung zu dir drängen ja
die gibt's auch schon siehst du ist ja
auch okay man braucht die ja weil sonst
muss man ja mit 50.000 reden aber so hat
man eben so zwei drei mit die man eher
öfter mal ganz genau sind das so deine
ersten Abonnenten oder was sind das für
ja die das sind diejenigen die von
Anfang an dabei waren und von denen ich
ganz genau weiß die sind immer dabei
egal was kommt die sind noch so ein
bisschen aus der Zeit wo du noch nicht
prominent warst so sagen ja genau und
von daher ist da schon mal ein
Vertrauensverhältnis was ja aber auch so
ist durch diese Tutorials oder dass du
eben sagst hier ich muss mich zeigen wie
ich bin das heißt du zeigst dich
Hunderttausenden wie du bist fehlt dir
dann nicht manchmal so ein Schutz weil
ein Schauspieler der spielt eine Rolle
ein Moderator spielt eigentlich auch
eine Rolle weil er stellvertretend den
Zuschauer die Fragen stellt aber du bist
du ist das nicht manchmal zu dich dran
ja klar es kommt aber immer darauf an
also Natürlichkeit jeder kann
Natürlichkeit ausstrahlen aber es kommt
immer drauf an was man von sich preis
gibt also was man jetzt von sich gibt
und ich denke jetzt nicht dass es jetzt
ein großes Problem ist also natürlich
kann jeder sein man sollte nur drauf
aufpassen nicht so viel verbal von sich
Preis zuug geben also das ist für dich
ganz wichtig da eine Grenze zu ziehen
und kommen dann nicht die Leute auch
deine positiven und wollen immer mehr
und mehr und mehr ja klar aber dann sage
ich auch einfach das ist viel zu privat
sowas beantworte ich nicht
und das verstehen sie wo ist da die
Grenze die
Grenze die Grenze kommt draf an jetzt wo
also meinst jetzt so alles ja
Privatsphäre wo beginnt deine
Privatsphäre worüber red deine
Schwestern sind ja auch schon mit dabei
das heißt wir wissen schon du hast zi
zwei Schwestern ne sind sie eigentlich
älter oder jünger als du sind ich habe
noch eine weitere Halbschwester also ja
genau aber ja sind alle älter als ich
alle älter als Du aber die hast du schon
mit reingeholt ja die machen ja also
meine andere Schwester macht zum Teil
auch erfolgreich Videos auf Youtube ja
ja da ist also schon schon ein Stück
wieder weiter
und ist man nicht der Gefahr
und ja sowas kann natürlich immer
passieren aber solange man nicht jetzt
nicht preis gibt wo man wohnt oder was
die Telefonnummer ist et ist
es ganz okay aber die Leute wissen immer
mehr über dich sie wissen dass ich Samy
heiße und 19 Jahre alt bin und aus
Stuttgart komme und mehr nicht wenn alle
deine Videos mal Review passieren lässt
dass du eine Schwester
hast gut wir wissen nicht was dein Vater
als Beruf macht oder wissen wir das Nein
wissen wir nicht was deine Mutter macht
wissen wir auch nicht was deine
Schwester macht wissen wir auch nicht
außer dass sie nein außer dass sie singt
und son n also das ist alles quasi
Privatsphäre Privatsphäre und würdest du
auch nicht wenn jetzt die Yellow Press
kommt und sagst wir wollen dringend eine
Homestory machen wirdst du ablehnen ganz
genau weil für mich ist wä es dann zu
sehr eingedrungen in meine Privatsphäre
und da will ich auch nicht zu nein will
ich nicht einfach Nein gut sehr
vernünftig was planst du für die Zukunft
was plane ich für die Zukunft die
Zukunft steht mir eigentlich offen also
in diesem Jahr habe ich z.B geplant
meine erste meine eigene t-shirtlinie
die Außenseite haben es vorgemacht aber
jetzt meine eigene selbstproduzierte
t-shirtlinie rauszubringen und ich bin
auch jetzt gerade schon am diskutieren
mit meinen Zuschauern welche Motive sie
gerne hätten welche Farben bei Ihnen
ganz gut ankommen würden und sowas z.B
das heißt das sind dann T-Shirts da
steht drauf abonniere mich nein nein
nein das sind dann ganz schlicht
gehaltene also nicht zu sehr auf
Propaganda hier her Tutorial und so also
sozusagen auch so meine mein eigenes
Produkt das heißt da ist auch richtig
schon eine finanzielle Idee hinter ja du
hast jetzt schon ganz okay verdient ich
weiß du darfst nicht drüber reden aber
es wird okay sein bist du zufrieden ich
bin sehr zufrieden bist sehr zufrieden
ja aber du planst das richtig
äh
generalstabsmäßig so kann man das auch
sagen aber natürlich immer mit meinen
Zuschauern was wie gesagt das ist das
A&O die Zuschauer ist das vielleicht
eine neue ich sag mal ein neues Prinzip
Geschäfte zu entwickeln du hast es schon
erzählt Kosmetikprodukte T-Shirts Mode
ja es haben jetzt schon genügend
Youtuber vorgemacht aus England oder aus
den USA die ihre eigene Produktlinie
rausgebracht haben und mit anhand ihrer
Abonnenten diese dieses Produkt dann
vermarkten konnten und damit auch Erfolg
haben das heißt man kann davon ausgehen
dass man dich in 20 Jahren noch auf
Youtube sieht garantiert also solange
ich noch fit und aktiv und so lustig
drauf bin wie ich jetzt bin ja
garantiert du bist immer so ich bin
immer ganz locker drauf also ja also so
wie ich dich jetzt erlebe wie du vor der
Kamera
ja ich lache eigentlich immer ich bin so
ein Paischer Mensch ich frag wozu sollte
ich ein grimmiges Gesicht ziehen was ist
wenn du mal sauer bist ja klar solche
Tage gibt's immer
aber es gibt immer etwas wofür es sich
zu lachen lohnt was wäre denn gewesen
wenn das jetzt bei YouTube nicht
geklappt hätte was wä denn was wäre dann
heute dann will ich jetzt immer noch
ganz normal Junge sein der ganz normal
sein Zivildienst ableistet und danach
studier K ich werde immer noch studieren
also youtube ist immer noch Plan B
und man sollte immer was in der Hand
haben wie me ver
sagt ja
okay das heißt t-shirtsie ist alles noch
Plan B es ist noch nicht so dass du
sagst ich setze da jetzt drauf ja also
man sollte immer ein Plan A haben und
Plan B und man weiß ja nie wie es
ankommt und man weiß ja nie wie es sich
entwickeln wird
also man sollte schon immer was sich was
haben gut dann wünsche ich dir dann
wünsche ich dir viel Erfolg bei deinem
Plan B der ja wahrscheinlich Plan A wird
oder was denkst Du ja denke ich schon
also es kann garantiert Plan A werden
passt das denn überhaupt zeitlich
Studium und Youtube weil du machst viele
Videos du musst die recherchieren wer
die Zeit wohl finden müssen irgendwo
muss ich die Zeit rauskratzen und es
muss sein dann also viel Erfolg dabei
Plan A und Plan B vielen Dank
durchzukriegen gut danke
schön